hey youtubers is Charlie so last week in
my Blackfyre rebellion video I promised
I'd do a golden company videos so this
is going to explain their history as
well as how they're gonna fit into the
show they're basically a big mercenary
company and Song of Ice and Fire
they got named Rob during season 4 on
the show which is a good indication that
we might end up seeing them if we
haven't already also be explaining my
Game of Thrones Comic Con giveaway at
the end of the video hello any new
people if you're finding me for the
first time I do weekly Game of Thrones
videos be sure to subscribe to get
everything
and congratulations to Noro you are this
week's book giveaway winner I'll be
messaging you for details that's a
weekly thing to the book giveaway all
you do to participate is be a subscriber
and leave a comment I'll pick one random
winner from the comments to get one of
Martin's books don't worry my word is as
good as gold that's actually a golden
company motto but certainly something I
try to live up to the golden company has
a couple of sayings and they give you an
idea of what goes on in their head space
the one that everyone quotes is our word
is as good as gold which is pretty
self-explanatory we don't break our word
and we'll do whatever our contracts say
we're gonna do that motto started in the
early days after the city of qohor
refused to pay a contract the company
had completed they basically sacked the
city is an answer and thus began the
reputation of fidelity their battle cry
is a little bit different it's beneath
the gold the bitter steel it's an homage
to the founder of the company aegor
rivers who's also known as bitter steel
he's the bastard half-brother of daemon
Blackfyre and the Bloodraven
they were all part of the first
Blackfyre rebellion in case you didn't
see the video I did for that I'll add a
link in the description the creation of
the golden company is tied up in the
events of the Blackfyre rebellion so
let's rewind a little bit to the end of
that war it took place a little bit over
a hundred years ago on the show at the
end of that rebellion bittersteel
managed to reclaim the Targaryen sword
black fire that had belonged to daemon
Blackfyre and all the Targaryen Kings
preceding him back to a gan the conquer
he took the sword and all the survivors
on the losing side of that war and fled
to ty Roche the Bloodraven was on the
other side of that war and bitter still
ended up taking one of his eyes out I
think the show didn't really follow up
on that whenever they showed the
three-eyed raven for those who haven't
read the books the Bloodraven
is the three-eyed raven it's just what
he was called before he became the
three-eyed Raven now he's just known as
the last green seer even though
akley bran should be called the last
greenseer but anyway all the black fire
survivors fled to the east and
established themselves with mercenary
companies that's what any highborn exile
trained in swordplay would do you know
they'd join a mercenary company it's a
lot easier choice for someone training
combat to make most highborn males and
Brienne's receive extensive weapon
training growing up the exception is is
when people decide to join the Citadel
and become masters the mercenary band
that bitter steel ended up joining was
the second son's but he was only with
them for about a year he left to form
his own mercenary company when he saw
several other exiled Lords joining other
mercenary companies all those people had
been supporters of the black fires
during the rebellion it was a way to
rally the banners of the other exiled
Lords in case they ever wanted support
for a future war of conquest so one
really interesting thing about all these
black fire survivors was is that they
had the blood of the Dragons flowing in
their veins you know the blood of Aegon
the fourth the one that sired the
initial bastards who all had their own
children daemon Blackfyre the first the
one who started the Blackfyre rebellion
had a son that survived that and went on
to live under a pseudonym in Westeros he
had what's called dragon dreams just
another word for foresight like the kind
of Daenerys the dreamer had and Daenerys
Targaryen on the show right now if you
don't remember that old Daenerys she's
the one that foresaw the doom of Valyria
and told them to GTFO before the
volcanoes blew people inside the black
fire lineage haven't always been leaders
or you know captains of the golden
company but it is interesting to think
about them using dragon dreams you know
that dragon's blood in the visions to
try and pick their battles up to where
we are in the show they've never broken
a contract so they make pretty good
choices because a lot of the rebellions
over the years have been tied to the
black fire survivors or sympathizers
whenever there is a new rebellion people
do seek out the golden company's help
because they were formed by black fires
that doesn't always guarantee that
they're gonna participate but they have
about 10,000 men so you definitely want
to get their help if you can for
instance in the events preceding season
one of the show Daenerys said that her
brother Viserys tried to get the support
of the golden company he feasted them
and tried to rally them to his banner
but they just laughed him out that's why
they had to marry Daenerys to Khal Drogo
because they needed his khalasar to use
his infantry so if the golden company
had backed the saris claim we might not
ever have met caldo
so just think about that there's
actually a really cool golden company
referenced tight to Viserys death if you
remember when Khal Drogo killed him by
pouring the molten gold all over his
head it was straight out of the books
obviously but you could also draw a
reference to the death of bittersteel
when bittersteel died he decreed that
his subordinates should boil his skull
dip it in gold put it on the banner and
carry it before them as they tried to
reclaim the Iron Throne that's why their
sigil is a spear with the golden skulls
on it boiling former commanders skulls
and dipping them a gold adding them to
the banner just became a tradition in
present day it's mandatory but you know
you're dead so what do you care what
they did with your skull ii Blackfyre
rebellion wasn't something that the
golden company participated in but
daemon Blackfyre ii started something it
turned into more of a small plot but the
golden company did participate in the
war of the ninepenny kings that was
another war that came on later that was
about 40 years after that failed ii
Blackfyre rebellion another black fire
descendent mallies the mantras and
several other cell swords
started the war of the ninepenny kings
it wasn't completely a Blackfyre war but
because they were led by malice black
fire the monstrous you could think of it
that way he was captain to the golden
company at that time
they basically carved out a whole bunch
of territory in the Free Cities for
themselves and then turned their eyes to
Westeros so because the golden company
has endured for so long and been
associated with so many wars to retake
the Iron Throne
or just take parts of Westeros a lot of
characters that you see on the show
right now have crossed paths with them
for instance sir Barristan the badass
was the one that killed malice the
monstrous he was called monstrous
because he was born with a conjoined
twin that fused in the womb so he had
this little head growing out of his neck
with a larger than normal upper body
like he had a giant upper body with a
tiny little head attached to his head
the tale that people told about him was
that he ate his twin inside the womb
thus he became monstrous it would be
like if the mountain had a little head
growing out of his shoulders that looked
a little bit like the hound imagine that
if you dare which is actually a pretty
good transition to present day on the
show so during season four sir Davos
mentioned them to Shireen whenever he
was talking about getting support for
Stannis he wasn't really thinking of
them in the context of the black fires
most of his interaction with them in the
past has been with Rick
to their activities purely as
mercenaries he basically suggested to
Stannis that they'd hire them using
money from the iron bank
daba said they have about 10,000 men but
there are a few differences in the way
the books and the show are treating them
in the books other characters only
believe that stan has hired the golden
company and took them to the wall which
really isn't what happened on the show
they kind of play it a little more
ambiguously but I think show Stannis
really did hire the golden company just
because they're combining a lot of
things from the books another small
change is that Jorah Mormont's said that
he used to fight with them on the show
and that's not true in the books the
main takeaway is that because the golden
company is made up of exiled Westerosi
Nobles they'd be much more willing to
sign a contract with anyone wanting to
reclaim or usurp the Iron Throne
although now on the show it seems like
Stannis the most likely candidate to
usurp the throne has turned his
attention to the White Walkers and
Season 5 on the show has a whole lot of
stuff from books 4 & 5 to draw from in
terms of story up at the wall so what
I'm gonna do now is talk about book 5
stuff so if you don't want spoilers for
anything and Dance with Dragons just
skip forward the video like 30 seconds
or turn the volume down
so I'll details about comic-con and
giveaway stuff after this so I'll wait
just a second remember just skip forward
or turn the volume down like 30 seconds
everybody ready okay here we go
the golden company comes back in a big
way book five via Jon connington and
young Griff who connington says is Aegon
Targaryen the supposed dead son of
Rhaegar the one the mountain is supposed
to have killed during the sack of King's
Landing connington uses Aegon to rally
the support of the golden company and it
becomes this whole big plot in Westeros
it's unclear whether or not the show is
gonna do any of this right now it seems
like they're gonna skip it as evidenced
by the golden company being at the wall
serving Stannis it's possible that they
could break that contract but I think
that Season five is mostly gonna focus
on Jon Snow and Stannis is stories and
books four and five the mark tells and
Dorne
Daenerys in the aftermath and King's
Landing in book four and five plus Varys
left King's Landing with Tyrion at the
end of season four that's a huge change
from the books to I think the he and
Tyrion are just gonna seek Daenerys out
or at least sir Jorah first then
Daenerys so I think they're just gonna
cut out all that young Griff stuff and
for those wondering yes I do think that
he's a Blackfyre I don't think he's
really Rhaegar son
I know cutting stuff out sucks but
remember Michelle Fairley is pretty sure
she's never going to be back to do late
Stoneheart so Dan and Dave completely
cutting big story arcs out has happened
before so in case you turn the volume
down you can turn it back up but here's
what's going on with Comic Con
I will be recording the panel but I have
a link to a special poll in the
description you can vote on which
comic-con panels you want me to upload
it'll really help me prioritize which
footage to post so please do the poll so
I'm gonna be posting one more game of
thrones bonus video before Comic Con
starts and that's where I'll explain the
giveaway a little bit more but basically
I'm gonna be giving away fandom related
toys for like all the different types of
videos I do in my show so naturally
there's gonna be a special Game of
Thrones giveaway again all you have to
do to participate is be a subscriber and
leave a comment whenever I post that
video it's just like any other giveaway
I do the Game of Thrones Comic Con panel
is actually on Friday July 25th so I
should be able to post the footage of
that by late Friday night internet at
Comic Con is really terrible just
because there's like a hundred thousand
people all trying to use it at the same
time but even if it takes longer
don't worry I'll still post the footage
so be sure to subscribe to get
everything it's gonna be a lot of fun
George our Martin always gets tons of
winds of winter questions and he's shown
no indication that he's gonna finish
before season 5 of the show starts next
year which means that by season 6 will
pretty much be even between the books in
the show so talking about spoilery
things won't really be an issue for book
readers I know it's been a little while
since I've done a wins a win or video
but I'll do one again really soon
because we actually know quite a bit of
stuff George our Martin is pretty good
about posting excerpts several times a
year
right now though you can click here to
learn all about the Blackfyre rebellion
basically the events that immediately
preceded the formation of the golden
company and you can click here to learn
all about the white Walker prophecy
thank you so much for watching I'll see
you guys tomorrow high fives